of all of the open-world games to come
out this year Xenoblade Chronicles X may
be the most formidable it is a truly
enormous game both in scale and scope
the towering animals and rock formations
stretching as far as the eye can see
even after as many as 60 hours X
continues to provide taller mountains to
climb and stronger opponents to topple
with no end of new challenges in sight
at the same time X is a prolonged RPG
with a predictable story and repetitive
lifeless characters you hear the same
jokes over and over again and endure
drawn-out cutscenes with little to no
emotional payoff like so many Japanese
made RPGs serious characters and moments
are undermined by the presence of a cute
and cuddly sidekick we aren't wincing at
the sight of Tatsu the game's stuffed
animal choice you may be reeling from
the soundtrack instead which is filled
with low-rent flops that make you reach
for the mute button and nothing is more
frustrating than when your success has
left a chance a sin that occurs an ex
more often than should these are reasons
enough to walk away from most games but
X isn't most games by offering a steady
stream of challenges and greater rewards
not to mention fantastic landscapes to
explore X has no problem enticing you
back for more despite its problems
your journey begins when you wake up
after being discovered in a Life pod on
planet mira a spaceship escaping earth
crash-landed on the planet after getting
caught up in an alien conflict and a few
humans that remain are left to fight for
their survival in the future of the
species as a member of blade the
military organization in charge of
scouring mira and defending humanity
your only goal is to locate the
invaluable pod known as the life hold
all housed in a structure called the
life during your search you travel
across alien lands and have to defend
yourself from hostile wildlife you and a
party of three ai-controlled characters
battle in a real-time combat system that
offers a lot of depth but unfortunately
like many of x's finer points you're
left to figure out how it all works on
your own every character has a melee in
a ranged weapon and depending on their
class a selection of offensive and
defensive skills at their disposal
now making use of these isn't difficult
but shortly after starting you soon
realized that not everything is under
your control instead of casting healing
spells are using consumable items to
patch up wounded warriors you rely on a
QTE system which is triggered by a
complex array of events in battle to
replenish your health sadly like many of
its advanced systems access and do a
good job of explaining how this works
something that is basic is healing in a
game what combat is central to the
experience should really be made clear
from the start
X does a poor job of explaining things
in general and you will spend a lot of
time with the in-game manual poring over
pages in search of information X allows
you to dive deep into character
development and resource management but
without guidance you will undoubtedly
get lost and sidelined more advanced
pursuits in order to continue exploring
and fighting if only because those
activities come so naturally you should
take the time to figure these subsystems
out though because they are the key to
unlocking new skills and tools that
allow you to continue hunting larger
creatures and reaping greater rewards
skills the game's giant robots are the
biggest reward of all after dozens of
hours exploring a massive planet on foot
the moment you jump into a pilot seat of
a skel is an awakening you are
considerably more powerful in combat and
when you transform into the scales
vehicle form you can cover large swaths
of land in no time it can take 30 hours
to get your first scale and that long
journey makes you truly appreciate your
new powers when they finally arrive with
multiple scales to purchase and dozens
of equipment to customize an upgrade you
will spend a lot of time filling out
your repertoire of scales but in order
to get to that point you have to
complete roughly half of X's main story
while the vagary surrounding X's
subsystems can be frustrating for
ambitious explorers
nothing is more confounding than X's
mission structure sometimes you're
required to arbitrarily explore a
certain amount of land or collect a
certain number of items in order to
access the next chapter of a story X
already has so many things for you to do
but the last thing it needs is missions
that Pat out the story unnecessarily you
often don't have enough time to do the
things you'd like to do let alone enough
time to flounder around completing
random tasks just to move to the next
part of the plot
Mira and its inhabitants are all
inspiring and experiencing everything X
has to offer is a monumental but
ultimately rewarding task it makes the
journey consistently interesting in
other ways by giving you intricate
control over your characters abilities
in gear unleashing created opportunities
over time you will roll your eyes at the
story and characters and beat your head
against the wall when you're forced to
mindlessly grind for the sake of patting
out the game's story but these
frustrations are quickly forgotten and
you head into the wilderness in search
of unexplored territory and unforeseen
challenges X is a great adventure that
sea sheets your appetite for exploration
in combat in ways that few games ever do
but because getting started is half the
battle it's an experience reserved for
dedicated players who have the patience
and energy to unearth its greatest
treasures
you